Speaker 1: Well, my friends, you did something
quite notable over the last 72 hours. Remember
that on Monday I came to you with almost tears
in my eyes and I told you about a disaster
facing many creators like me on YouTube. And
I asked you take some simple steps, simple
actions. And many of you did. And the results
are stunning. And they have turned up quite a
bit of interesting information. Now, before I
get the results, I'll quickly remind you what
went down on January 9th. Mysteriously, there was
a six hour period during which our live analytics
on YouTube showed that we were getting almost no
views, not like 10% less than we normally get,
but almost zero. Some hours we got 1900 views When
we would normally get 100,000 views. This impacted
our channel. It impacted other people in and out
of left wing politics on YouTube. YouTube told us,
Your views are fine. It's merely a reporting
glitch. We're going to fix the glitch, but
views are completely fine. The next day, things
were supposedly fixed and after 3 to 4 days,
some slightly higher numbers were retroactively
updated in our analytics for that weird six hour
period on January 9th. But views were dead, the
channel was dead, subscribers were flat. One day
we even lost subscribers after gaining subscribers
basically every day for years and years. We
actually ended the day with fewer subscribers than
we started. Since January 9th. The channel's been
anemic videos that after 90 minutes after
2 hours, have 2000 or fewer views. Again,
something that hasn't happened for years. Do the
math. You know that this is just a mathematical
reality. We come to learn these things from doing
this for so long with 1.6 million subscribers, the
mathematical possibility of ending up with 2000
views on a video, it doesn't pass the sniff test
views down 60 70% revenue down 60 70% subscribers
at a crawl, happening not just to our channel but
to the channels of others you know as well. So I
asked you to do something really simple. First,
search YouTube for David Pakman. Click on one
of our videos and the results. Do it a second
time. Do it a third time. The key is search for me
and then click on my videos. We are training the
YouTube algorithm. When you click on my videos,
make sure you are subscribed. Many people watch
the clips, but don't subscribe. That's bad for us
in the algorithm and make sure after subscribing
you click the bell and select that you want to
be notified. Please like the video I said, and
if you can please leave a comment. The idea was
if YouTube shows you my videos in the recommended
videos, you click on another you comment you like,
you keep a string going. This if nothing would
show that if there was nothing nefarious that took
place, maybe we fell out of the algorithm because
of that glitch on January 9th, so maybe we can fix
it. So here's what went down as soon as that video
went live on Monday at 4 p.m. Eastern explaining
what was going on, we started promoting the hell
out of this video. We dumped every resource. We
had massive dumps to artificially drive traffic
to the video as much as we could. The video
picked up over 450,000 views as of yesterday
and even more now. And something incredible
happened. That video generated more than
13,000 new YouTube subscribers. But did it
fix the algorithm? Is the next question. Well,
yes and no. The next video we published, meaning
Monday at 530 Eastern, was a video about Donald
Trump's absurd eulogy of Diamond from Diamond
and Silk. And that video did okay. It got about
200,000 views, still really good. So it seemed as
though the activity from the 4 p.m. video did help
us in the algorithm when the next video went live.
But after that things sort of went to crap again.
But there are some really important takeaways
here, it seems. And again, we are working with
zero transparency, so we're just kind of feeling
around in the dark. It seems that we can force our
content back into the recommendation engine. It
seems that the dumping everything we had into that
4:00 video did lead to more recommendations for
the 530 video, but then things trailed off. Things
are sustaining themselves the way they used to. So
for now, the good news is if we keep at it, if we
keep trying to retrain the algorithm in this way,
as I'm talking about, it might pay dividends. It
also might not work. So please keep it up, keep up
the like comment subscribe stuff. Now, I also want
to mention because people have emailed me, said,
David, you sound extraordinarily naive. I am not
so naive that I believe we can fix this ourselves
alone. And reporters have reached out to me since
this video went out there talking to me and other
YouTubers about what's going on. I'm hopeful that
an article or more than an article will be
written about what's going on and publish soon
to maybe shine more of a spotlight on this. In the
meantime, please keep doing these things. They are
simple and they are free and if you can afford it,
get a membership at join Packman dot com. We are
down in revenue dramatically. We were counting on
the YouTube revenue to launch the Spanish language
YouTube channel which is scheduled to launch
soon. So if in addition to those free things,
you can get a membership for a couple of bucks a
month. You can do that at join Packman dot com. Of
course you get the bonus show. Why not.
Speaker 2: Oh the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: You get the whole thing and you
can use the coupon code. 24 starts now to
get yourself a discount. But thank you. I mean,
just incredible what folks have been able to do.